can we fix or improve the m2 macbook
air's thermal throttling issue well
today we're gonna try it out with these
guys right here this is a thermal pad
and we have a set of them and this is
gonna allow us to help transfer the heat
from the m2 chip faster away from it and
into the chassis itself now in our
previous video we did a full teardown we
showed off the chip and we showed off
the metal casing and shielding the apple
has on this macbook and people reached
out and said this is not a vapor chamber
this is simply shielding for all of
those sensitive components and we saw in
our thermal test how hot that cpu got
how quick he heated up and that most of
the heat was concentrated right there in
the center using our thermal camera now
we also got some benchmarks we know how
much it throttles and how fast it
throttles and also some real world
testing so let's go ahead and open this
thing up so we can do this easy and
simple and cheap modification i'll go
ahead and link those thermal pads on
amazon down in the video description now
as i unscrew these four simple bolts on
the m2 macbook air i have to tell you
about our giveaway because we're gonna
give away a brand new m2 macbook air and
i don't care where you are in the world
i will pay for the shipping i will pay
for any import taxes or fees that way
everybody can participate and all you
have to do is one be subscribed to the
channel and two comment on our launch
week videos for the m2 macbook air you
can comment once per video and on monday
july 25th we'll be announcing the winner
live in a video our goal is to hit a
million subscribers by that date so even
if you don't care about winning one of
these if you want to help us out and you
enjoy our content and our honest reviews
and testing please hit that subscribe
button now this case is almost removed
we got to pull back here all right there
it is and as you can see this is kind of
marked up already
now we've done our thermal testing and
some people were saying well if you
already took it apart uh you're going to
mess it up and it's going to thermal
throughout the way more well ours
actually performs slightly better than
other reviewers that we've seen so maybe
we actually improved it before we even
do this test let's go ahead and grab our
first chunk now we actually used these
in our previous video for the m1 macbook
air
and we're going to reuse them just
because other ones are taking too long
to come in but you can order a larger
sheet and then have it be perfectly cut
to size for this and we'll put the
second one right here and these are just
designed to grab heat quickly and
disperse it and i have a couple scrap
pieces
that we pre-cut
that will fit perfectly bam right there
so we have this whole section covered
over here and you guys see here i have
nothing now underneath this section
there is actually no motherboard at all
which is what we found in our teardown
so the part with the motherboard is
completely covered here but of course if
i had more thermal pads i would probably
just run it all the way across and now
let's go and see if we can close this
cover these are a little bit on the
thicker side they do have thinner ones
so i'd probably buy a long thinner sheet
if you're going to do this yourself all
right one side went in there goes the
other side wow okay that is perfect
thankfully everything works the machine
is running and before we do our
cinebench test i'm going to go ahead and
open up adobe lightroom classic uh we've
already done a run before we did this
mod we didn't show it off in our thermal
comparison
and we're just going to go ahead and do
another one of these exports and see if
we have any improvement and bam let's
hit our export for these 50 edited 42
megapixel images all right we're one
minute into this export and our temps
are pretty low now one thing is this is
using both the cpu and the graphics it's
close to maxing out the graphics and the
cpu right now it's kind of bouncing
between 24 23 they'll go 70 80 percent
so the temps kind of go up and then they
drop down but it does seem to be running
uh cooler than it did last time and with
that it is definitely moving faster so
we are getting some good improvements
we're at a minute and 50 seconds we are
almost done now
oh okay
okay
um
yes now this is we just did one run
that took a minute and 56 seconds to
export these 50 images now the m2
macbook pro with the active cooling fan
takes two minutes consistently to run
this export now that is taking longer
i don't know if it does throttle
slightly but we do know with that
machine even under cinebench it does
throttle at first because apple waits
way too long to crank up that fan it's
like over 100 degrees by the time it
cranks it up whereas here the heat is
getting taken from that chip through the
thermal paste and then through that
metal and then into those pads and
spread it out so that literally did that
faster now wait until you find out how
long it took before we added those pads
take a guess down below how long that
took all right this one took a minute
and 56 seconds with a thermal mod fix
and then without it it took two minutes
and 55 seconds now that is crazy fast i
want to pick this up and feel
i definitely feel some heat on the
bottom and that was literally less than
a two minute render so that seems to be
working surprisingly well so it must
have not throttled at all
whereas the m2 macbook pro does throttle
a little bit before the fan kicks up and
then the one without this thermofix
definitely was throttling when we were
you know hitting the cpu 80 and the gpu
we were kind of surprised i mean that
definitely got slower than two minutes
at that 255 mark so wow okay very
impressive a bigger difference than i
expected and now let's go ahead and run
cinebench the first run i'm not gonna
have my cpu frequency and wattage
monitoring software open uh last time we
did a single run just the same way
and it took just 28 seconds to hit 108
degrees let's see how it does this time
99 100 after 40 seconds 101
still getting hot pretty quick now of
course
that chip is getting saturated very
quickly that is where our temperature
sensor is at and then that heat is going
to get drawn out so looks like we're at
almost a minute now we still have not
hit 108 degrees we're hitting 104 and
now still pretty dang hot and bam we
just hit 180 degrees took about a minute
and 23 seconds compared to 28 seconds of
course this is maxing out our cpu so if
you're doing things that do max it out
and it cools down a bit you will avoid
hitting those really high temps and look
at that score right there 8
684
that is
incredible itch that beats out of course
the original run that we had of 85 51
which already was much higher than the
8200 that luke miani got and other
people got lower scores proving that our
we did not damage ours by taking it
apart but that literally not only beat
that that also beats our m2 macbook pro
we just retested it just to make sure it
was sitting there on the desk not being
touched all day in an ac room cool we
ran it once and it got 85 57 and this
with a thermal mod just got 8 684
very very good results now last time we
did a bunch of runs so i'm gonna do it
the same exact way this time and we'll
see what the difference is in
performance after each consecutive run
and how fast it drops off round number
two we're 8619
still
last time our second run was 8
351. 84.95
we're slowing down a little bit but it
is still almost at the point of the best
score we got and still way better than
luke miani's macbook stock run 4 is 8
240.
that is still it they believe better
than luke miani's very first run and
defeating the 7792
that we got without the thermal fix 8151
now for our fifth run we've been running
close to 10 minutes now compared to 7542
without the thermal fix guys
this is going even better than i
expected i'm pretty impressed
8072 compared to 7454
i wonder if we can maintain above 8 000
that would be crazy now i do see that
our frequency does start slowing down it
is of course doing better than it did
before and our wattage is running higher
whereas before it got all the way down
to like 9 watts where it would still
perform decently but put out a lot less
heat
8056 i thought it was gonna dip under
but it didn't compared to
last time instead of 8056
thousand three hundred and thirty on
that run so we're on our eighth run now
and a lot of people did three four runs
we're on our eighth run it's been about
15 minutes
and the performance is still doing great
uh it's doing
similar to what a lot of people got just
out of the box so it's very impressive
with very little drop so if some people
got for example luke i know he got 8200
at its best from a cold start first run
and we're still at 8056
after 15 minutes of hammering the cpu
that is awesome all right bam we got
7738
we did dip below
uh the 8 000 which would have been
amazing but that was actually the run
that got the lowest score previously in
our series 7 295 and then it went up by
a little bit so it seems like after
about 15 minutes or so
that's when it finally gets saturated
and when you get the first big dip in
performance compared to before where we
would see a dip like that even on the
second run so we're almost done with our
very extended testing
and it looks like we're getting 47
degrees celsius right here now that was
the peak that i saw previously
but this time it just looks like it's
more spread out along the chassis
even up here to the corner top left so
we are getting a lot more spread of that
heat uh compared to before and then
let's take a look at the bottom here 47
degrees celsius as well
so what i heard is that 50 is kind of
the legal limit because you can get
burned uh so thankfully we're not at
that 50 yet and the macbook does start
to throttle itself we ended up with 2.65
gigahertz
on that last run just like we did the
first time and our final run was 7619
compared to 7302
so that is when the macbook is
completely heat soaked those pads are
heat soaked the actual chassis is as
well but if you didn't count those last
couple of rounds that brought us closer
to 20 minutes of testing the first 15
were phenomenal we stayed above 8 000
compared to before that it was like
three four minutes and we're already
just crashing in performance so
very very good results way better than i
expected so that was testing the cpu
what about the graphics well now we're
going to run 3d marks wildlife extreme
stress test this is going to take 20
minutes and it's going to map out the
results and we can directly compare
to not having this thermal pad how high
our scores are and how long it takes to
drop off and then get heat soaked so
let's go ahead and get started all right
we are done and the results are
fascinating now right out of the gate
our stability is actually lower than it
was before
and that is because we had high scores
and then after it got heat soaked at the
end it dropped down
but when we look at this actual chart
look how stable it is for the first
seven minutes it didn't go down at all
and our seventh run was 5618
whereas before we were at 4473
a massive difference now here is a
screenshot of our run before and what
you see is that on our fourth run it
starts going down and our fifth run was
a huge nose dive in performance down to
4329
here on our fifth run we're still at
5631
and then if we scroll all the way over
here we had a little bit of weirdness
going to the 10th run we actually didn't
notice but our battery is getting really
low and then on the 10th run or 10th or
11th round we plugged it in you see bam
the score starts shooting up again and
it was running great so here
realistically we only see a big dip in
performance close to 4 000
when we were running or at a4 about 16
or so minutes whereas before the four to
five minute mark we saw a huge dip which
means that
one we can maintain 100 graphics
performance for a lot longer and
realistically before you get heat soaked
and lose a lot of performance you
literally instead of doing that the four
to five minute mark it's about this 15
16 minute mark so you get an extra 10
minutes or basically what does that mean
three times longer of 100 gp performance
before you just fall through with
thermal throttling so yes it definitely
helps graphics as well so what do we
figure out overall well
this really not only helps you get
slightly better performance and even m2
macbook pro in some cases it helps real
world tasks like photo editing that was
incredible
and it just allows your system to have
much better performance when you're
really hammering it for a longer period
of time and so as long as you're not
doing like 20 30 an hour long renders an
m2 macbook air with a thermal fix can do
just as good of a job compared to the m2
macbook pro that actually has a fan but
you guys let us know your thoughts down
below make sure you guys comment if you
guys want a chance to win click that
circle to subscribe check out one of
those great videos right over there
that's been max and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]